it's like when another part of the
episode of the shop with Drake we really
explained Kanye and push a tee when that
rap feud exploded in May so push it in
Drake treated diss tracks and then push
to drop the story I've added on where he
revealed Drake had a son hmm
yeah and on the shop drink revealed that
it must have been Kanye who produced
pushes album that told him about Drake's
son since Drake had just revealed it to
him a couple of weeks before that Drake
actually decided not to respond with his
own diss track and explained why here we
thrive off competitive nature course but
there was you know people love to say
like rap purists and people who just
love conversation they'd love to say hey
man there's no rules and but there are
rules in it of course and I'm gonna tell
you something it's like I knew something
was gonna come up about my kid they had
to add like the deadbeat thing to make
it more appealing which is fine I
understand that and I even that I was
like okay the mom and dad thing whatever
you don't even know my family's like
some let me tell you wishing death on my
friend that has MS I study rap battles
for a living now when you mentioned
defenseless people who are sick in the
hospital that passed away that really
sent me to a place where you know I just
believed then and believe now that
there's just a price that you have to
pay for that and I just listened back to
it and I was like man this is not this
is not something I ever want to be
remembered for this is not even a place
that I necessarily want to go and to all
the people who enjoy that I tip my hat
to you by the way hell of a chess move
this song I thought it was trash but the
chess move was was genius back against
the wall I either go all the way filthy
or I fall back and I have this sort of
[ __ ] in my armor for the rest of of
time to a rap terrorist which is fine I
can live with that you know I would much
rather live with that than the things
that I was about to the research I did
is that I was gonna say and the places
that I was gonna go not only for him but
the other guy too
you know and now I just I feel pure I'm
good yeah a lot of people want him to go
hard I did did you yeah I'm right fair
yeah and so
but don't get what he's saying that if
he did that there's no going back yeah
I've heard a lot of stories even about
some of the stuff and information he had
all speculations but from what I heard
what it is it's like he was gonna ruin a
lot of people's 19 careers but personal
lives yeah
which because I saw that interview
yesterday I watched that whole thing
about how Kanye flew mode to Wyoming and
you've got him to work on his elbow and
then Drake kind of took him aside told
him owed his kid and then it dirty
it's super grimy is dirty it's easy like
Kanye to me is and I'm a Kanye fan like
I his first album ii helped a guy who
produces own stuff real you know middle
class guy talking about life issues it's
kind of where I came from but now like
you hear that and just Kanye in general
was like I almost think he's doing it
you remember Andy Kaufman how we used to
do that [ __ ] stuff back in the day yeah
I almost feel like he's just doing this
and it's gonna come out in a few months
I'll be like it's just a big game yeah
he's completely crazy difference and
speaking of just Kanye quickly I would
buy all of that and I would actually be
okay with all of that if the music was
still good I don't even care about the
music like I listen to it like I'll
throw it on to check it out and Kanye
fan but it annoys to hear his voice
right like when I hear him talk or give
his points I'm just annoyed to be like I
don't want to hear anything you have to
say man like I for him on Twitter I see
what he says every day to me he's just
like a dude starving for attention which
is crazy because he's Kanye West but
it's like it's sad it's corny it's
pathetic it's just black to me yeah some
people are having like mixed reactions
to like rap battles in general Carla
says they want to see who raps better in
a rap battle but that's thing like where
do you draw the line what you're allowed
to say but it's like Drake say you know
what's rules and I disagree because I
watch battle rap but I know Drake does
cuz I've seen him at these king of the
dot things and these events there's no
rules in that no I've seen
Pat stay say some stuff that I'm not
gonna repeat on TV but it's accepted in
this battle rap world where you can make
fun of disabled brothers and sisters you
can make fun of their mother
it's all on the table I think there's a
difference though when you say that
stuff to win and when you say that stuff
to hurt I think that two people being on
stage battling each other ways to play
it's different than what happened here
it's like the the the Machine Gun Kelly
Eminem fight that they tried to trump up
you know that last month where I was and
even that it's like like I'm not a
Machine Gun Kelly fan at all but I
thought he came correct on the dish yeah
I heard it was like Oh played the M&M
one become me and my boys are in the
studio all the mmm just come out shucked
it on within a minute and a half we kind
of started talking about something else
it was just like oh oh yeah this is on
and I'm a huge Eminem fan but I don't
know it's a fan I love seeing this oh
that's like who these guys that you know
you might look up to or whatever it is
and really go in bar say get some
personal stuff and you learn just a lot
of stuff I got pushed it to you when the
Drake was like yeah you know the kid
mentioned obviously but just I've never
seen anyone take a shot like that a
Drake and actually hit him you think
like it's not just saying with MGK I'd
ever seen anyone draw blood from Eminem
I feel like he did that yeah but do you
think it's a vital thing for the hip-hop
culture and industry to have these I
don't know not like battles and feuds
that come up every one so no I don't
think it's vital I think it's exciting
yeah it's cool couple weeks and it's
it's over currently the idea of Drake
and Kanye going at it was that's like
Tyson Hollyfield you know what I mean
it's finally it's oh my god to see you
happy is the face yes like to me that
would be bigger than the McGregor
Merriweather